peanuts are the most common food allergy
in kids it's actually cow's milk you can
cure food allergies you cannot cure food
allergies right now the best way to find
out if you have a food allergy is to get
tested
myth hi my name is dr weiwei lee i am a
board-certified adult and pediatric
allergy immunology specialist i have
been in practice in new jersey for the
past 10 years hi everyone my name is dr
pyle gupta and i am the co-founder and
chief medical officer at cleared and
i've been practicing in new york city
for over 12 years today we'll be
debunking myths about food allergies
peanuts are the most common food allergy
so even though peanuts is a common food
allergy it is not the most common in
adults it's actually a cross between
peanuts and shellfish in kids it's
actually cow's milk so the nine most
common food allergens are cow's milk
eggs
peanuts tree nuts
shellfish fish
wheat soy and sesame peanut allergies
grab more headline because they tend to
cause more severe reactions especially
in kids other foods like cow's milk and
eggs when you have those allergies in
infancy you'll grow out of them but for
peanuts that allergy you're not going to
grow out of and so i think that for
those reasons it just kind of caught on
a little bit more than some of the other
food allergens you can use benadryl to
treat an allergic reaction you should
not use benadryl as the only means of
treating an allergic reaction for food
allergies in particular benadryl is an
oral antihistamine it can help with mild
symptoms such as itchiness or hive but
if you have more than just itchiness or
hive like symptoms of anaphylaxis such
as trouble breathing difficulty
swallowing tongue swelling or feeling
dizzy because of blood pressure dropping
you really should go to your epinephrine
auto injector the saying is epi first
and epi fast food allergies and full
intolerances are the same thing i see
that a lot of people even sometimes
medical professionals will confuse the
two but they're really different so food
allergies are actually mediated by our
immune system and they're caused by an
antibody called ige in our immune system
that reacts to food when it shouldn't
when that happens we release a chemical
called histamine which then produces all
of those symptoms like hives difficulty
breathing low blood pressure swelling on
the face of the eyes of the tongue
vomiting and sometimes even death
food intolerances or sometimes called
food sensitivities don't have any of
that they are not mediated by our immune
system you have more
gastrointestinal symptoms and they are
not
life-threatening for example lactose
intolerance is a big one that people
have an issue with it's actually an
enzyme deficiency in your body where you
can't digest lactose because you don't
have the enzyme called lactase and so
you're going to have that bloating
sometimes diarrhea
and just general feeling of not feeling
good after you ingest things with cow's
milk or with lactose knowing the
difference between food allergies and
food intolerance will determine what
kind of treatment you need to receive
food sensitivity testing is accurate you
just don't have good tests to determine
if somebody has a food sensitivity there
are commercially available
tests called igg food specific igg
testing they're not fda approved we
see igg as a memory test to show that
you have eaten the food not an allergic
reaction to the food which is different
than true food allergy testing which is
an ige test so those igg tests that are
often sold online we don't go by them
instead of testing we would recommend a
food diary where you can keep track of
your symptoms the foods that you've been
eating and then over time we'll start to
see some
patterns that's actually the most
accurate and helpful tool that we have
at this time to help determine food
sensitivities the best way to find out
if you have a food allergy is to get
tested
myth
the best way to find out if you have
food allergies is to eat it and to see
if you have symptoms after eating it so
that's called oral challenge which is
considered a gold standard in diagnosing
food allergies it's very safe and it's
in a controlled setting with emergency
medication on hand you can get an ige
blood test done at home we might get
people showing up as possible positives
to some of the foods but it doesn't mean
anything unless you've actually reacted
to the food for example if i have a
patient that comes in who ate peanut and
shrimp sauce
and then they had a reaction and we're
trying to determine was it the shrimp or
was it the peanut that they were
reacting to that's when those ige tests
and the skin tests that we do are super
helpful in helping us determine what the
person reacted to
you can cure food allergies you cannot
cure food allergies right now the only
food that we currently have an fda
approved protocol for is for peanut
allergy oral immunotherapy for peanut
allergy is where you get small amounts
of the peanut allergen over time in the
beginning you get monitored to make sure
that you're not having reactions right
away and then the critical thing is to
take that amount of peanut every single
day if they don't if they miss a dose
then it could kind of set things back
and they could have a reaction the next
time that they're exposed to the peanut
protein and i'll add to that the oral
immunotherapy will lead to a temporary
state of desensitization or tolerance
but not a permanent cure i will avoid
the word cure because it can lead to
misunderstanding for patients allergic
reactions won't happen if you didn't
swallow the food
myth even touching the food without
ingesting the food can cause allergic
reaction that's why it's important to
not you know touch a food and then touch
somebody that has an allergy to that
food with shellfish allergy in
particular because shellfish is usually
steamed or boiled sometimes the food
allergen protein from the shellfish can
actually end up in some of that steam or
that vapor and so therefore it is to a
certain degree airborne and if somebody
who's highly allergic to that food
enters a room where shellfish is being
boiled or cooked they may start having
symptoms even without ingesting the food
each allergic reaction will be worse
than the last so that's a myth the
reaction can be unpredictable reactions
to food are unpredictable because there
are multiple factors that go into play
so what was the exposure and how much of
it asthma that can worsen the severity
of your reactions and so adding an
additional
component of inflammation and irritation
will make your symptoms worse if your
child has eczema they will also develop
food allergy not every child with eczema
is going to have a food allergy but
if the child does have eczema there
might be a higher likelihood that they
could have a food allergy having eczema
and having allergies they all belong to
the atopic disease spectrum which refers
to asthma eczema and seasonal or
environmental allergies so if your
infant develop eczema at a very young
age it's important to determine if the
child has other atopic diseases as a
trigger for their eczema symptoms if
your first child has a food allergy your
next child will have one also food
allergy within a family member is a risk
factor but it doesn't mean that you'll
definitely have a food allergy having
risk factors really just increase the
risk of developing the food allergies
and it also doesn't mean that you'll
have the same food allergy so if your
dad has a shellfish allergy that doesn't
mean that you're destined to have a
shellfish allergy yourself and we don't
know a lot about factors contributing to
the development of food allergies all we
know are the risk factors throwing up
will make your allergic reaction less
severe that is not true your allergic
reactions to food
is dependent on exposure to the
allergens throwing up will not make the
exposure less essentially throwing up is
just exposing your body to that food all
over again in a different way coming up
instead of going down having to throw up
after have eaten the food could be a
sign of anaphylaxis which is a
life-threatening reaction but
self-induced vomiting would not lessen
the symptoms of food allergic reactions
food is supposed to be something
enjoyable we're supposed to eat
something at least three times a day and
so we don't want to put unnecessary
stress around it if you're worried at
all it's super important to go and see a
specialist that feel passionate about
food allergies so that we can help
figure out what your history is and
figure out what the right testing and
what the right treatment plan will be
for you